Announcer:
The number six seed in the East,
the Terrapins of Maryland,
out of the Big Ten.
They will play the winner
of the first four games...
[ Crowd cheers ]
...in Dayton, Ohio, Wednesday.
Who will they be?
[ Crowd cheers ]
University of Central Florida.
Congrats to UCF and
Elhadji Sereigne Tacko Diop Fall
who is 7'6" and one of
the 10 tallest living people
in the world.
We shot this
before the tournament,
so I assume my Knights
have already humiliated
number-one Duke and that
over-hyped Zion Williamson.
Don't @ me.
[ Laughter ]
March Madness is in full bloom.
Like watching the NBA
if no one ever made a shot.
Not everyone loves exploiting
student athletes,
but everyone loves a bracket.
So we created one
for a region
that often gets overlooked,
despite having
over a trillion people.
It's the Far East Video Bracket.
Now, they've definitely got
some sweet-and-sour contenders.
Like the number-five seed,
Naked Tablecloth Guy.
[ Upbeat music plays ]
Announcer: The man knows how
to display his fine china!
Silky smooth!
Delightful!
Of course,
the number-three seed,
Wrench Ninja,
breezed through.
[ Upbeat music plays ]
They call that move
the ouching tiger!
Face Punch Boy
is easily
the strongest number-one seed
in the field.
Such a tough competitor.
[ Upbeat music plays ]
The best offense
is zero defense!
But the real Spinderella story
is the number-10 seed
that shocked the world --
Spinning Water Monk.
[ Upbeat music plays ]
Oh, baby!
This is passed down from the
Buddhist tradition of Dasani.
That is what I am talking about!
Such grace! Such control
over his or her body!
Oh!
You have got to be kidding me!
Like Virginia basketball,
he's consistent,
but goddamn it, he's boring.
♪♪
His stomach just received
total enlightenment!
I spoke too soon!
The Spinning Monk
heaved up a prayer
at the buzzer to win
the championship.
Give him his moment.
♪ In one shining moment,
it's all on the line ♪
Truly inspiring.